pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec olivier delamarche économise
bonsoir olivier delamarche merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
tout d'abord sur cette analyse d'ubs
l'occasion déjà de vous interviewez la
semaine dernière vous n'étiez pas
vraiment optimiste vous devriez donc à
trop d'accord avec le fmi la récession
mondiale pour être bien pire que la
crise financière de 2008
c'est une évidence qui est triste c'est
que le fmi nous nous sortent ça
maintenant comme s'il avait découvert le
fil à couper le beurre
franchement on sait tous que ça sera
plus fort que 2008 2008 c'était c'était
quelque chose qui est arrivé pas du tout
dans les mêmes dans les mêmes conditions
que qu'aujourd'hui est donc évidemment
ça va être beaucoup plus fort en 2008
vous n'aviez pas des pays totalement
arrêtée comme aujourd'hui comme l'italie
peut l'être comme la france qui
fonctionne petra à 10% de ce qu'elle de
ce qu'elle devrait et que bientôt les
états unis ça sera pareil
donc on peut pas imaginer que ça soit la
même crise qu'en 2008 c'est une simple
il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir des analyses
pour ça alors quelles pourraient être
les conséquences selon vous on entend
souvent des voiles à des discours de la
rue mais quand même certains crient à la
faillite des banques vous ayez carrément
jusqu'à ce genre de diagnostic des
prêtres toute façon les banques elles
sont elles sont en faillite depuis
depuis un bon moment je vous rappelle
que deutsche bank n'a pas attendu le
corps navires us pour être en faillite
or c'était quand même une des plus
belles banques européennes donc
maintenant se poser la question de
savoir s'il va y en avoir d'autres
oui je vous l'annoncerai y en avoir
d'autres donc maintenant qu'est ce qui
se passe et ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir justement la réaction des
marchés par rapport à quelque chose qui
était attendu aussi qui est une sorte de
japonisation
de toutes les banques centrales vous
avez la banque centrale américaine qui a
annoncé aujourd'hui que elle faisait
tapis comme poker c'est à dire c'était
open bar pour tout le monde et donc
j'achète tout n'importe quoi dans des
proportions qui sont délirantes et donc
on voit que ils ont toujours le même
réflexe 1 donc on essaie de régler un
problème en rajoutant de la bête en
imprimant massive en massivement on sait
que ça ne fera rien sur l'économie
réelle mais il ça aujourd'hui
la preuve en est voilà la réaction de
wall street on est presque à 5% baisse
là on voit que ça n'a pas plus d'effets
maintenant sur le les marchés financiers
pourquoi pas tout simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui le marché il est persuadé
d'une chose c'est qu'on ne peut pas
sortir de ce 2 7 de cette situation
c'est à dire que vous allez avoir petit
à petit comme la banque du japon l'a
fait qui va tout acheter qui achètera
aussi des actions qui achètera des au tf
et qui remettra sans arrêt un petit peu
plus d'argent parce que sinon s'ils ne
sont pas là et bien les marchés
s'écroule et donc mais olivier marc
capelle comme votre choix la fed
enfin les banques centrales compte elle
comme autre choix que de faire ça mais
c'est aux banques centrales
quand tu veux on pouvait se poser la
question en 2008 en 2008
ce qu'ils ont mis en place était nouveau
ils ont fait un quantitative easing en
disant il ya un problème de liquidités
on injecte de la liquidité
mais rassurez vous après ça sera terminé
bon on a bien vu que ce n'était pas
terminé et que ça continue même encore
douze ans plus tard et ont su on s'y
remet on a interrompu pendant quelques
temps à peine et puis on s'y remet
pourquoi parce que justement c'est
quelque chose dont on ne peut pas sortir
donc ça n'est pas la solution on sait
que ça n'est pas la solution
alors c'est quoi c'est deux minutes de
plus monsieur le bourreau c'est ridicule
on va s'endetter pour des générations va
on va détruire la monnaie tout ça pour
quoi
tout ça pour tenir quelques quelques
semaines de plus
mais c'est grotesque alors quelle salle
fc lyon d'avoir enfin et si on réfléchir
autrement je veux dire on a vu ça ne
marchait pas maintenant si c'est pas
quelque chose c'est pas comme si c'était
expérimental et que on pouvait se dire
bah peut-être que ça va marcher ça on
pouvait peut-être se le dire en 2008
bien que beaucoup de voix à ce moment là
disaient que ça ne marcherait pas et
avec raison
et là aujourd'hui on recommence la même
chose en se disant peut-être que cette
fois ci ça a marché banon pas plus que
la première fois
alors quelles seraient les solutions
remettre tout le système à plat une
bonne foi porto tu as mais je pense
qu'il faut remettre tout le système à
plat une bonne fois pour toutes oui
parce que je pense qu'il va il va être
temps 1 de changer les équipes parce que
excusez moi pour l'instant aucun a
prouvé son efficacité donc et ça dans
tous les pays donc changer les équipes
et réfléchir autrement là aujourd'hui je
pense que ce qu'on a ce qu'on a quand
même pu voir à l'occasion de cette crise
c'est qu'il y avait pas d'europe
l'union européenne c'est un truc qui
n'existe pas
chacun tire dans son coin chacun ferme
ses frontières pendant ce temps là il y
en a un qui dit qu'il faut pas les
fermer
il ya un stock de masques qui arrive à
prague il le confisque c'était direction
italie enfin je veux dire elle est où
l'europe elle n'existe pas donc
qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui vient aider
les italiens c'est les chinois c'est les
russes et c'est même une équipe
d'infirmiers cubain c'est pas des
européens donc ça n'existe pas donc je
pense qu'à la fin de ces crises et
heureusement je pense que ça va ça va
éveiller tout le monde et notamment les
italiens je pense que ils demanderont
leur sortie de l'union européenne et et
tant mieux
je veux dire on voit que c'est quelque
chose qui ne marche pas ça nous coûte
une fortune
mais ça ne marche pas c'est c'est
vraiment ces organismes européens
c'est un ça me fait penser ses vaches
que je vais dire mais ça me fait penser
à la poubelle jaune de recyclage si les
recyclages des politiques qui ont échoué
dans les différentes dans les différents
pays et qu on recase en europe pour
qu'ils trouvent un boulot mais que je
suis désolé mais malheureusement c'est
pas la solution
merci beaucoup olivier delamarche
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france